hello right now time to turn to the
Press preview which is a first look at
what is on the front pages as they as
they arrive and it's now time to see
what's making headlines for the sky's
political commentator samachar and we're
also joined by the particular editor of
the HuffPost UK Kevin field good to have
you both with us and they'll be with us
now from now until just before midnight
so lots of time to talk through the news
and let's have a quick look first shall
we let's have a look at what is on some
of those front pages as they come in
the queen was like everyone's
grandmother the express leads with what
the Prince of Wales told one Warner at
sunderingham today
staying at sunderingham the Metro
reports on the emotional toll the
Queen's death has had on Prince William
walk behind Queen's coffin brought back
memories of my mother's funeral The
Daily Mail also dedicates its front page
to the prince's words today and the
telegraph has some new details
concerning the Queen's funeral which
will be a course on Monday with NHS
doctors and nurses set to walk in front
of Her Majesty's coffin
the son says that Prince Harry will wear
his military uniform when he stands
visual in front of the Queen's coffin in
the coming days
and the mirror reports on the funeral of
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Cobell who of
course was shot by a gunman who broke
into her home in Liverpool last month
the financial times has word on that
meeting between Vladimir Putin and the
Chinese president where Mr Putin
admitted for the first time that Beijing
had concerns over Russia's war in
Ukraine
and the guardian's top story focuses on
the prime minister's plans to lift a ban
on fracking which the paper says comes
despite an apparent lack of progress on
limiting the risk of earthquakes caused
by the practice
pray for the poor millionaire Bankers
that is the Daily Star which leads with
news that the chancellor wants to scrap
the cap on Bankers bonuses
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code that you can see on screen during
the program you can also check out the
front pages of tomorrow's newspapers
while you watch ours digest them as well
and as I said before we are joined by
Sky's political commentators and
political editor of the Hub post at UK
Kevin Schofield really good to have you
with us from now till just before
midnight great stuff let's have a look
shall we in a lot of the papers starting
with the Daily Express are focusing on
um Prince William's words it was really
quite emotional from him wasn't it it's
interesting yeah and I think it's um
it's amazing really that uh he's out
there and he's obviously having to lead
the charge now that he is Prince of
Wales and uh really capturing that
sentiment that a lot of people say you
know the queen was uh like everybody's
grandmother I mean I can't say that I
can particularly relate to it but that
kind of like sense of of that of that
National figure but also interestingly
people feeling especially you know with
the line of people going through
Westminster Hall here
um that sense of sort of delayed grief
from the pandemic and things like that
so you know that sense of um a
familiarity almost with that figure not
just because she's our queen or was our
Queen but also because of people that we
may have lost you know through the last
couple of years so really capturing that
sentiment I think I think a lot of
people probably quite surprised by how
emotional they felt I was quite taken
abat by it actually when the news came
through it just felt quite untethering
somehow like yeah I think it's because
obviously she's been part of all her
lives I mean you have to be very very
old basically not to remember when she
wasn't
the Monarch and yeah I mean someone is
in your life even if you don't know them
and they're a distant figure but you see
them on the TV they're just as you see a
presence they're always there and I mean
suddenly that's gone I think yeah it
does it surprises you and it upsets a
lot of people and you know you see it
when you look at the
the live feed of the line and stay
I think a lot of people if you see them
coming through they probably don't know
how they're going to react until they
actually get there and you see some
people are crying others bow their heads
others blow kisses bless themselves you
know it's it's it stirs up all sorts of
emotions that people just don't expect I
think it is interesting and talking
about how the queen was like everyone's
grandmother it is that personal
connection that many people felt they
had with her even though as you said
they don't know her they may never have
met her but it's the familiarity perhaps
I think when she when you have a figure
like that that's sort of constantly
um you know pictured and on your TV
screen and therefore the big National
moments there's it's really difficult
not to have some sense of relatability
to it and also the royal family is
designed in some ways for us to be able
to relate to them you know whether it's
kind of like
holidays or you know weddings or births
you know we're supposed to have that
kind of a sense that they are a bit like
us so I think that emotion is really
palpable at this moment in time and it
does it does feel like you know somebody
that you know has gone and that's why
you are seeing this strong reaction I
don't know if you saw that Theresa May
was also and she's been clipped and she
was also in in the in the line sort of
joining everybody else
um and you know she had quite a
grief-stricken face as well and this is
somebody who was in in a public eye
Frontline politics for a very long time
and I don't think you can underestimate
just how much emotion the queen can
evoke
um you know even now and it's and how
traumatic it does feel for people even
those who are in close proximity to her
if you're supposed to have a bit of a
stiff upper lip really that you'd expect
that Teresa certainly yeah you
definitely would wouldn't you not
necessarily someone who wears a heart on
the sleeve yeah and I was just quick
funny actually I'm not not terribly
funny but before the left to come here
my daughter she's only six were I was
putting her to bed
and all of a sudden she started crying
and I thought it was because I was
making her way to bed and I was like
what's wrong and she'd come up beside me
she was you know at school today there
was pictures of the queen everywhere and
I found it very upsetting and she's only
six it's not being one of the first
conversations she's had about death
about some of these really she has lots
of questions about that yeah absolutely
I I when I came down here for the first
time on Sunday I overheard a
conversation by a girl probably about
the same age with her mum and she was
asking questions like how does the queen
get up to the sky and it's it's it's
processing that it's very public sort of
morning as well isn't it yeah as I said
she's only six but you know she had only
ever known the queen and the queen was
on Peppa Pig and all these types of
things Paddington beer you know so in a
strange way even at that age they could
relate to the queen and the idea that
she's no longer there even at that age I
think I'm upset yeah it's true
um let's go to the Metro now shall we
you are also focusing on some of what
the uh The Prince and Princess of Wales
said at Sandringham uh don't cry you'll
start me off and then the very emotional
personal conversation he had saying that
what happened going behind the Queen's
coffin brought back a few memories
yeah I mean it's um it's interesting as
well with the queen herself I think came
from a generation where the Royals
didn't really emote you know they didn't
share their feelings uh terribly much at
all if it was obviously Williams from a
different generation and it's almost
second nature you know they feel
comfortable it helps them to relate to
members of the public uh and yeah I mean
it is it must be quite the
is 25 years now
um and he's having it basically retraces
the same steps that he took as a little
boy and behind his mums often having to
do that again 25 years later you can
understand why it brings back pretty
images of the two boys the two young
boys 1997 going behind the the coffin it
was incredibly traumatic yeah it must
have been traumatic for them and also
you know given that there's obviously
difficulties in their relationship at
the moment you know
hopefully there is something positive
from this and that perhaps their Rift
can heal a little bit you know reminding
themselves about what they went through
together but I think there's a there's a
wider Point here is that the royal
family don't get to have their grief in
private you know they have to you know
as it is have their grief in in public
and we were sort of thinking about this
earlier and maybe it's the fact that um
you know they get some Solace from the
fact that the public shares in their
grief
um but there must be some downsides with
having to as I say keep that stiff upper
lip yeah or not good on William actually
for uh you know showing a bit of the
emotion perhaps Charming was on the
mental health stuff he's done as well
and talking about that very public grief
we're getting some details up we about
the funeral they're expecting for the
queen with Daily Telegraph saying NHS
doctors and nurses to walk ahead of the
coffin
yeah I think this is a great idea
um and you know it's important I think
especially at this time you know we've
just come through the pandemic obviously
came out and clapped and banged our pots
and pans for the NHS so it's important I
think that they are recognized in this
way and also with cost of living crisis
there's a I think there's a there's a
risk that
that seem all this Pomp and ceremony
might just seem completely out of touch
and not chain with what other people are
going through and this I think having
members of the public uh walking ahead
of the coffin as well we've been part of
the whole funeral service I think is a
really good idea yeah that's a good
point actually isn't it about the the
Grandeur and sort of resplendency of all
of the pump and sound against the
reality that people are facing as well
yeah and what's interesting about this
is that um it was that the Queen's own
request that she wanted not only members
of the public at the funeral so there
are people coming in from all over the
Commonwealth who've done good works
um around her Realms
um but also the fact that I think she
does have a real or sorry forgive me did
have a real sick sense of this kind of
thing and you saw it in the Olympic
Games when she did that little skit with
James Bond and you saw it with the
Paddington but just that sense of
actually being inclusive and finding
that way to be relatable as a monarch
and and show that she is connected to
her country absolutely no no reason to
apologize for getting the tenses really
I feel like we're all kind of still
processing getting used to it I've seen
Prince Charles
you have to check yourself almost
sometimes when you just talked about the
prince and princess of Wales my mental
image was for something else completely
yeah well it's because we we aren't
missing new reality isn't it that we
um that we are looking into now
um a couple of other stories uh to uh
talk about as well and you picked out
the guardian front page trust to lift
the fracking band despite the lack of
progress on Tremor risks and I guess
this is a reminder that despite the
national pause other news are still
confumbling on as well absolutely and
the Politics as normal has been put on
hold but
um
come next Tuesday once we're past the
funeral things are going to speed up and
return to normal very quickly and the
energy crisis and the government's
um announcement that they made this time
last week but which hasn't had any
coverage really because of the Queen's
death is going to be front and center
and the fracking ban being lifted was
one of the elements of that announcement
which probably didn't get the coverage
that it should have done at the time
that we were told to that day that the
British Geological Survey which was an
investigation into potential side
effects of fracking was going to be
published last Thursday that didn't
happen for whatever reason and the
guardian of now seen a leaked copy of it
and it's basically saying that you know
there is no firm evidence that fracking
is safe
but despite that and despite the fact
that the conservative Manifesto says it
won't go ahead unless it's proven to be
safe they're still going to go ahead
um and that's going to be hugely
controversial
I'm just going to pick out a slight
Nuance in the guardian coffee here
having been a former special advisor and
having I'm probably having to deal with
you Kevin on the other hand
s
like
me now yeah
um
you know not seeing the full report and
just going off what's in the copy it's
not that it's proven to be unsafe it's
that they don't have enough evidence to
say it either way and I think this
creates Catch-22 situation because if
you're not granting more licenses for
for exploration of fracking then you're
never really going to be able to gather
the data that gives you the sense of you
know whether it's a go or no-go and so
it doesn't technically break the
conservative Manifesto if they going for
this Drilling and you know they start
detecting the Tremors over 0.5 I think
the question would then be legitimate to
say actually are you really doing this
safely but you know until we've seen
this report in full I don't think we can
make any assumptions we are in this
slightly incredible situation where we
have these big policy announcements with
lots of questions remaining and there's
been no scrutiny so far I mean I guess
like you said that's going to change
pretty quickly yeah I think we're going
to get um an announcement uh or a debate
at least in Parliament maybe Wednesday
or Thursday next week I mean the other
day I'm gonna offer is that companies
the private sector
um businesses have been told that they
will get an equivalent scheme to the one
that's being announced for households
but there's no no details when it's
going to come in and businesses that
need to make decisions now yeah
um as to what deals they sign up for
over the winter and it could mean lots
of them go to business so that is one
thing that the government needs to come
up with pretty quickly it's actually not
just even about the fact that businesses
are facing hardship it's actually we
don't know how we're going to pay for
any of this and that is really
problematic or how much is the cost at
the minute isn't it yeah right so so we
need some detail on this pretty fast
well we'll wait and see and like say I
think the pressure will be on once uh
next week comes around
um I do want to talk to you about the
Daily Mirror at front page because this
is the it says mother's heartbreak and
it is absolutely heartbreaking the story
there goodnight Olivia love you
um the mum of uh Olivia practical who of
course was the little girl who was
killed in Liverpool saying I will never
say goodbye but what I will say is good
night I mean it's just
I think it's it's um
the first the initial news was of course
really shocking but when you look at the
pictures of you know this small pink
curse going into a church it actually
makes it so much more real
um and seeing her mother you know
cuddling her toys and things like that
you know it's actually it's probably
some of the most heartbreaking pictures
you'll see in tomorrow's papers and um
you know it's pleasing that the police
have made progress with the rest but I
don't think it's going to be much
comfort for her mother
no I mean obviously we're we're talking
about another funeral which is coming up
on Monday but this it stops you in your
tracks really as you say when you saw
the The Carriage carrying the tiny
little coffin in the church I mean see
as a parent and you don't even have to
be a parent it's a human being really to
know how
before all for the story is and how
devastating it is for our family and you
just hope that they get Justice I mean
it will never bring Olivia back
um tragically you know on such a young
life snuffed out but um but yeah you
just hope that as I said they'll get
some kind of justice but it's just a
heartbreaking story yeah the report
earlier I thought the the comment by
someone saying that you know coffin
shouldn't should never be that small was
actually really did sum up didn't it you
know this is this is a nine-year-old
girl and it's in the other thing that
has really struck me is just how
eloquent her mother has been uh today um
in the face of the most enormous grief
she really has been so eloquent in in
talking about her daughters it's quite
quite cool
yeah I just don't know how you would
ever cope with it really uh and and for
it to happen such a tragic way you know
snuffed out so quickly and needlessly
and violently
um is just horrific and as I said you
know hopefully someone will be brought
to Justice fingers crossed certainly
right let's um move on to the next story
shall we and this is about Anchor's
bonuses so it's more politics and this
is the Daily Star which is
cool coverage recently hasn't it the
headline there pray for the poor
millionaire bankers and this is the
story of course about the chancellor
quasi called reportedly changing the
rules which are designed to cap Bankers
bonuses what do you think about this
politically then
so there was a reason Bankers bonuses
were capped back in the day and it's
largely because you know the banks were
um responsible for a recession and a
crash back in 2008 and and we the
government had to take on Earth we the
taxpayer were paying for them and so
that's why Bankers bonuses were brought
in
um I think it's very hard politically to
sell a message in such difficult times
that actually you're going to let people
who can earn a lot of money earn a lot
more money when everybody else is
struggling
um I I think you know the chancellor may
wish to explain his logic if he does go
through with this plan and say that he
wants to bring in as much investment and
as much money as possible I think that
he is going to have to work really hard
to offset that with people being angry
about the fact that you know there is
going to be that much uh inequality
um in the way that people are being
treated it's it's a politically risky
move to say the least isn't it to do
this as you say
um is this about the new government's
policy about just going for growth at
all costs doing everything they think is
they got in their Arsenal to to get work
yes and and a word I mean yeah they've
said and let's just say during the total
division contest that she wanted to
break with the treasury Orthodoxy
um and yeah this is they're going all in
basically to try and go for growth but
you know I can just about see the
economic argument to it I don't think it
would actually raise that much money but
it's like sending a message that the UK
is open for business it's the same
reason why they've said no more to have
an extra windfall tax on the energy
funds but politically you know trying to
sell this to people at a time when you
know they don't know how they're going
to pay their next gas bill but they're
going to just lift the bonuses on people
who are already they're lifting the
captain buddies on people already and
huge salaries
um I mean whether they're just trying to
get all this tough stuff out the way
quickly now and then they can move on I
mean in a way you could say it's a
little bit refreshing having come from
Boris Johnson who was so populist who
wouldn't do anything might possibly
custom votes now we've gone the other
way you know it doesn't seem you make
the Care at the moment about potentially
taking a hit in their opinion post and I
guess they're just banking on economic
growth and that will bring them through
at the other end which is a gambling at
southford right because every government
wants to get growth but it doesn't
necessarily mean you can get it right
this this is a unique situation though
because it's in the context of brexit so
we know that our financial sector which
is responsible for a huge part of the
economy in the financial sector is you
know above 10 of GDP is at risk from
centers like Paris and Frankfurt and in
order to stem the flow of that
hemorrhaging of that Talent this seems
like a very
um good thing to do but it is going to
be a really tough sell politically so I
do agree you know where they're trying
to get the hard stuff out of the way
quickly in order to try and build it up
for later build up some capital for
later we've just got a couple of minutes
so let's have a quick look shall we at
the Mac cartoon on the front page of the
Daily Telegraph always worth looking at
map cartoon it's one of my favorite sort
of points in the paper and today he is
sketching out the final Journey For King
Charles's leaky he got very frustrated
out yesterday didn't he were you
sympathetic with Prince Charles or
Prince Charles King Charles for ruffling
with his pen in the way he did
but
[Laughter]
yeah
but I mean I also felt sorry for the
quarters or whatever you call them
Hoover but also like just like desperate
for everything to go perfectly and as
soon as he starts kicking up with that
the elite pen and take the pen off him
and clean it up and what have you and
them yeah but I'm sorry Kevin you'd be
the first person to have a go if he was
covered in ink when he came out
exactly my favorite point about that
that's that was for him admitting he'd
been signing the wrong date which was
kind of like it didn't no one's really
picked up
on the day of the week he's kidding he
can do what he likes I mean he's
obviously his mum's just died and he's
been in the public glare and he's not
stopped for a second and it's probably
understandable that he kicks off about
something absolutely right I'm really
interested to talk we'll have more out
from you thank you uh so much to uh two
guests political commentator summer Shah
took an editor The Hub face UK Kevin
Schofield